e
herkese Merhaba değerli katılımcılar
bugün sizlere elimden geldiğince
yönetimde kadın Anlatmaya çalışacağım
Önce şöyle başlamak istiyorum kadın ve
erkeğin Sizce iş yaşamında eşit
oranlarda temsil edildiğini görüyor
musunuz bu soruyor bazılarımız Evet
bazılarımız Hayır diyebilir ancak gerçek
şu ki bu cam tavan sendromu dediğimiz
bir algı var
öğrencilik yıllarında insan kaynakları
eğitim derslerinde kariyer konusu
anlatılırken hocalarımız bize bu konuyu
anlatırdı bu konu anlatıldığı zaman
anandan duramazdım diğer arkadaşlarım
gibi nasıl oluyor da benzer eğitime
benzer yeteneklere sahip erkek ve kadın
çalışma yaşamında yönetim kademelerinde
aynı şekilde temsil edilemiyordu bu
sorunu aklını kurcalar dururdum Ama
sonrasında hem Özel sektörde hem de kamu
kurum bu gördüğüm kadarıyla bu durum
biraz olsada gerçeği yansıtıyor ve
verilere baktığımızda da onun Aslında
tamamen gerçeği yansıttığını görürüz
dünya çapındaki birçok şirketin yönetim
kurulları başkanlarının oranlarına
baktığımızda sadece kadınların yüzde
yirmi oranında temsil ettiğini görüyoruz
Yine üst düzey kadın yönetici
dediğimizde ve bunun 2020-21 yılı
verilerine baktığımızda kadın üst düzey
yönetici oranı şu an ülkemizde yüzde
32.6 tüm dünyada Pardon dolu ise biz ha
ne kadar aynı eğitimi alsak da benzer
yeteneklere sahip olsak da beraber işe
gidip beraber eve gelsek de Neticede
kadınlara anlamında yönetici düzeylerini
ayrıntılı kavuruyoruz ne ki neden
birçok sebebi var en temel sebeplerden
bir tanesi Aslı cinsiye kadar rollerimiz
cinsiyete dayalı rolleri ilk açıklayan
Freud şöyle diyor bu döneminde kız
çocukları bebeklerde oynuyor erkek
çocuklara baktığımızda Onlarda araba
silah ve benzeri Oyuncaklarla oynuyor
Dolayısıyla Biz aslında kız çocuklarına
daha çocukluk döneminde anneliği
hazırlarken erkek çocuklarında rekabet
otorite girişimcilik ya da mücadeleci
gibi kavramlarla biraz daha dışarı
odaklı projeler hazırlıyoruz
ve kız çocukları annelik roller ile
bütünleşir Ken kişilik gelişimleri bu
yönde gelişirken erkek çocukları ise ev
dışındaki daha çok çevre odaklı rollerle
bütün düşüyor Ve çocukluk döneminde
Ergenlik dönemine kadar olan dönemde
Aslında kişilik gelişimi tamamlanıyor ve
toplumsal anlamda rollerimiz de
netleşiyor
sonrasında Tabii ki bir üniversite
hayatı iş hayatı ve evlilik hayatı
kariyer başlıyor kız çocuğu çok iyi bir
üniversitede eğitim olsa
iyi niteliklere sahip olsan et ya
bekleyen bir ev ve aile yaşamı var yani
sorumluluklar ve top içilen toplumsal
roller var Ve tabii ki kadın bir tercih
yapmak noktasına geliyor kendisine
biçimde
biçimlendirilen rolü kabul ediyor Benim
rolüm evde çocuk bakımı ve bürolüks
eleştiriyor çalışmaya devam ediyor ama
ev ekonomisine katkı sağlayarak yöneten
değil yönetilen olayım diyor ve çalışma
devam ediyor Aslında bir anlamda rolünü
kabulleniyor ve geri plana çekiliyor bu
durumda Tabii ki yönetici pozisyonları
erkek adaylara daha uygun hale geliyor
Bu Peki bu durumda ne yapacağız başarılı
bir genç kız iyi bir eğitim alan bir
genç kızı biz nasıl üst düzey yönetici
yapacağız veya toplumda yönetim
kademelerinde bu kadınlara göreceğiz
çocukluk döneminden başlayan meslek
seçimi dönemine kadar olan bütün birçok
süreçte Aslında rollerimizi bütünleşti
yoruz ve bu olayı da kırıyoruz meslekler
o erkek kız ayrımı vuruyor Aslında bazı
meslekleri kadınlarla özdeşleşti yoruz
bazı meslekler erkeklerle
erkekse mühendis Doktor olabilir
elektronik Melis olabilir inşaat
mühendisi olabilir makine mühendisi
olabilir ama kız ise öğretmen olabilir
hemşire olabilir Örneğin şimdi sorsam
bayanlar veya kadınlar için en uygun
Meslek nedir desem belki birçoğunuz
öğretmenliği söyleyecektir Hatta sınıf
öğretmenliği veya anaokulu öğretmenliği
ile diyebiliriz Dolayısıyla Öğretim
şeylerimiz kabul etmesekte Aslında bizim
gerçeğimiz
açık olmak gerekirse ben de ulaşırsınız
sahiptim lise son sınıfta İngilizce
öğretmeni olmak istediğim için İngilizce
bölümünü tercih ettim ve çevremde
gördüğüm rol modelleri de öyleydi
sonrasında
Babam dedi ki daha farklı meslek
seçebilirsin mesela mühendis
olabilirsiniz mesela Doktor olabilirsin
düşündüm bir erkeksin Vestel
gönderiyordum bu mantıklıydı ve ben de
tercih değiştirdim hemen olanını seçtim
Evet muyuz Be Doktor olmadım işte bölümü
okudum ve Çünkü bölümdeki model işletme
mezunuydu babam aynı okuldan mezun Ben
de onun okuduğu okulu kazandım işte sen
bölümü okudum Tabi bu ürünü okur kendi
kendime bir takım sorular sormaya
başladı daha ilk öğrencilerin ilk
aylarında neden İşletme Bölümü okuyorum
ya ben Bunu okuyunca ne olacağım
bitirdiğimde hangi ünvana sahip olacağım
ya ne iş yapacağım Bu sonra kafama of
için kurcalamaya başladı bu sorulara
cevap aramak için en iyisi iş arıyorum
iş bulayım çalışayım gerçekliği işletme
göreyim istedim ve iş ilanları bakmaya
başladım hızlıca tabi çalışma şartlarına
uygun bir okul yaşamı vardı çünkü ikinci
öğretim öğrencisiydim yani çalışacak çok
zamanım vardı iş ilanlarını başvurdum
kariyer net üzerine özgeçmişim gönderdim
hızlıca Ne oldu
Kumsal şirketlerden bir tanesi Az önce
özgeçmişimde dokundu Aynen türknete
şirketine geri dönüş oldu iş başvuru
kabul edilmiştir ve görüşmeye gittim ilk
görüşmeye gittiğim gün bir kadın üstünde
yönetici ile görüşecektim geldim
kapısının önüne
sekreteri şöyle dedi Ayşe Hanım içeride
çok gergin üzülmüştüm ilk defa bir kadın
yönetici de görüşecek gibi çok yaygın ve
beni bekliyordum içeri girdim şimdi
qy19 yaşındasın buraya gelmişsin hiç
başvuru yapması ne iş yapacaksın burada
ben de uygun görürseniz yaparım dedim
Peki dedi asık bir yüzle
Hangi okulda okuyorsun söyledim ama ben
de okuldan mezun dedim ısınmıştı bir
gülümsemeye başlamıştı bu İngilizce
biliyor musun dedi bilmiyorum dedim bir
yıl İngilizce hazırlık okudum
konuşabilirim yazabilirim dedim gece
Peki o zaman ya Bu işe başla dedi İş
almıştım bu güzel bir şey de ertesi gün
ilk iş günü işe gittim asansöre bindim
asansörde Beni tanımayan bir kadına Bir
Erkek kendi Aralarında konuşuyorlar
barar erkek kadına şöyle diyor 19
yaşındaki bir kız işi Almışlar O kız
Burada ne iş yapabilir bir kadın da
şöyle cevap verdi öğrenir yetişir ve
yapar onlar benden önce Aslan söylediler
Ben de yukarı çıktım Tabii ki bir hali
moralim bozulmuştu
Çünkü gerçekten bana ne yapacağımı
bilmiyorum çalışmak için de doğru
yöneldim hoşça gittim birlikte
çalışacağım yönetici ne yapacağımı
gösterdi dosyaları aşırı diyecektim
Bilgisayara veri giriş yapacaktım
telefonlar bakacaktım ve iş yapmaya
başladım görevimi
mi Tabi sonra babam da şöyle diyordu
senin için okumak iş değil o Ben iş
buldum için mutluyum çünkü gerçekten bir
işletme görmüştüm ve artık bu
başaracağım da yavaş yavaş anlamaya
başlamıştım Zaman çok hızlı geçiyor her
gün sabah 8'de işe başlıyorum önce yarı
zamanlı çalıştım işler sonra her gün
geldiler dörde kadar çalışıyorum dörtte
çıkıyorum saat beşte dersin var Oraya
yetişiyorum tabi kurumsal bir şirket
kılık kıyafet kuralları var okul
kıyafeti okula gidiyorum okula gittin mi
arkadaşlarım gülüyor o fotokopi kız
geldi diyorlar
Ben iş yaptın da çok merak ediyorlar
onları anlatmaya çalışıyorum iş yaptım
çok da İnanmıyorlar Böyle bir dönemde bu
sözler size geç kalıyorum arada
gidemiyorum devamsızlık yapıyorum Hatta
bir gün muhasebe hocalarımızdan bir
tanesine dersleri çalıştığım için devam
edemeyeceğim ye Bir Söz Söyleme
gafletinde bulundum Hoca da bana o zaman
da Aslan kalırsın dedi seni çalışmamız
ilgilendirmez dedim Neticede olduktan
kaldım gerçekten de okulun tek bir ders
yüzünden bir dönem uzadı tembellikten
kitabı çalış çalışmaktan dolayı kalmış
En
çok da önemsemedim Neticede bir işim
vardı ve devam ettim
tabii hiçbir zaman kot pantolon ve spor
ayakkabıyla Okula Gidemedim veya
otobüs yolculukları ders çalıştım final
dönemlerinin ya da gece 12'den sonra
çalıştım normal mesai saatleri
içerisinde de gündüz hiç ders çalışmadım
final sınavına dahil nihayetinde iş
okulu üçgeninde geçen beş yılın ardından
aslında bir işim vardı tüm Lisans
eğitimim süresince aynı şehirde farklı
pozisyonlarda devam ettim lisans
eğitimini tamamladığını tabi iş aramadım
diye arkadaşlarımı sararken benim için
hazırdı daha iyi hızında daha iyi
ücretle işte çiçekler kabul ettim ve
aynı yerde çalışmaya devam ettim ama bu
sırada yüksek lisans yapmak istiyordum
dudaklarımızı çok kuruluyordu 180s
yapmak isteğimi söyledim biz sana izin
veremeyiz burada artık Tam zamanlı
olarak çalışıyorsun dediler yapamadım
kaldı bir süre daha devam ettim ama bir
yandan bu istek O başka sebeplerde
eklenince bir nokta koymaya karar verdim
özel sektörden ayrıldım Tabu sana yüksek
sanatına lan hazırlandım öğrenci
döneminde puanlarımı almıştım Bunlar
ihmal etmiştim ve
yüksek lisansa başladım bu süreçte
eğitime devam ederken öğretim görevlisi
olarak da çalışma fırsatım oldu
hiçbir dönemde ailem her zaman şanssız
asla hiçbir Anne bana ders çalış dediler
eve girdiler ya da Dışarı gitme
demediler Hatta Okulu dese birlikte
bitirdiğimde annemi ne düşünüyorsunuz
diye sorduklarında Annem söylemişti Biz
şanslıydık Çünkü çarşıya çıkardık pek
istediği şey bizden kitapta
okuldan eve gelir odasına girer diye ne
kadar çıkmazdı ders
çalışıyorduk şans de dikiş televizyon
setini görmedik burada ara Televizyon
izlemiyorum odacık oğlum Evet okumayı
düşük akademik Eser üretme isteği bu
heveslerle akademik Hayata bir anlamda
geçiş yaptım ve 380 akabinde Doktor
eğitimde devam ettim aslında Özel sektör
benim için kapanmıştı Doktor eğitim
esnasında bu işteki kaldım da geri
dönmeyi düşündüm Ama
doktora Eğitimi ve akademik ayar daha
cazip kağıdı için devam ettim Bazen çok
düşündüm acaba Özel sektörde kalsaydım
ve geri dönseydim dediğim zamanlarda
olmadı değil oldu
böyle bir dönem rakocevic kariyer dönemi
bu dönemde de üniversite çeşitli
görevler üstlendim bölüm başkan
yardımcılığı dekan yardımcılığı
Yüksekokulu
kendim yine en sürdürdü ve şimdi olduğu
gibi rektör yardımcılığı görevinde
istiyorum Bu süreçlerde hep gördüm
Aslında kadınların yönetim süreçleri
daha farklı bakış açısıyla yaklaştığı
ydı
yönetim fonksiyonları oluşan bir süreç
planlama ile başlıyor ve ben kadınları
çok farklı bir planlama sürecini
gerçekleştirdiğini gördüm ve kamu
kurumları hem Özel sektörde kadın çok
detaylı planlıyor en ince ayrıntısına
kadar kadın nasıl ne zaman niçin
sorularına cevap arıyor bir erkek ne kim
derken kadın nasıl ne zaman niçin
sorguluyor Tıpkı ev yaşamındaki her şeyi
organize edip planlandığı gibi akşam
inecek alışverişe ne zaman gidecek
marketten ne olacak ki misafirliğe
gidecek bunlar kadın organize etme
becerisi hem yaşamın organize ettiği
gibi kadın Aslında iş yaşamında da çok
rahat organizasyon yapabiliyor ve bunu
en iyi yeteneğiyle yerine getiriyor
kadın duygusal zekâsıyla ekip
yönetebiliyor biderlik yapabiliyor
motive edebiliyor ve duygusal zeka bazen
kadınlar için dezavantaj olarak
görülüyor Aslında tartışılır
tartışılıyor da bazı bilim adamları
duygusal zekânın bize zaman taşı
olduğunu kadınlar için bazıları Savaş
olduğunu söylüyordu bu zeka nedir
duygusal zeka bir bireyin karşısındaki
duygularını anlama sezme ve yönetme
becerisi kadınlar bunu iyi yapıyor kabul
edelim karşımızdaki duygularını iyi
anlıyoruz iyi fark ediyoruz Bu da bize
sosyal farkındalık sağlıyor aslında
farkındalığımızı yüksek u yüksek
farkındalıkla Biz çevreye daha duyarlı
yız şu çevreye daha duyarlı olduğumuz
için biz ekip başındaysa Eğer bu mm
ihtiyaçlarını isteklerini duygularını
anlayarak daha iyi yönetiyoruz Yani daha
iyi liderlik yapabiliyoruz Tıpkı evde
çocuklara yaptığımız gibi ders
çalışıyorum ödevini yap kızım ilme sahip
olmak için daha çok çalışmalısın
dediğimiz gibi aynı rolü Biz iş
yaşamında da ekibimizi motive ederek
Aynur yerine getirebiliyoruz Dolayısıyla
Biz yorgan üzere bir planlama yapıp iyi
motive edip yi kontrol yapıyoruz kontrol
etmeyi seviyoruz kontrol kadının
doğasında var
bu kontrol etmek istiyor Evdeki her şeyi
kontrol ediyor fotoğraflar ödendi mi
Çocuklar ödevlerini yaptı mı var bizim
kontrol alırız ve bunu aynı şekilde iş
yaşamında da Fark ettirmeden de olsa
yapıyoruz bazen de fark ettirerek
yapıyoruz ama kontrolü de iyi beceriyor
Uz Gerçek anlam
ve yönetim bütün fonksiyonları başarıyla
yerine getiriyoruz Ama tek bir kötü
özelliğimiz var o da kıskançlık Maalesef
ki bu kıskançlık duygusunun önüne
geçemiyoruz ve hatta buna literatürde
kraliçe arı sendromu Hatta pembe taciz
de deniyor nedir karı çağır sendromu
Kılıç örü bir kadının kendi
hemcinslerinin yükselmesine engelleme
yönünde çabalaması bunu bir çok örnek
var En ilter'e
başbakanı Margaret thatcher'ın aynı şeyi
kendi kabinesindeki kadınlara yapıyor
Belli bir dönemde Dolayısıyla bu
kraliçeyle sendromunu biz bir kadın
olarak maalesef hemcinslerini yapıyoruz
kadın sadece hemcinslerinden dolayı
yükselemiyor değil kadın ve erkek
arasında farklı sıfatlar var 100 kadını
Narin'in sevgi dolu merhametli vicdanlı
olarak kodluyoruz erkeği daha farklı
sıfatlarla konuşuyoruz Erkek bizim için
rekabetçi mücadeleci savaşçı Dolayısıyla
Bunlar yönetim ünvanlarına yönetim
sıfatlarına daha uygun Yani bir erkek
dediğimizde neden yönetici Çünkü erkek
kodladığımı sıfatlar Var erkeğin bu
sıfatlarla kokladığımızda kadına ise
sıcak sıfatlarla kutladığımız da o zaman
kadının bir adım geriye çekiyoruz kadın
bizim için sıcak kelimeler temsil eden
bir varlıktır Dolayısıyla yönetim
kademelerine erkeklerden daha geri
planda kalabiliyorlar
barsi yok kadın olduğunda çok dikkat
çekiyor ama bir siyah bu babası hiçbir
sorun yok baba bir şey olabilir a bu
video kadınsa ve bu anne ise bu kadın
nasıl yolluk yapacak nasıl yönetecek
koca şirketi soruları karşımıza çıkıyor
ve birçok şirket bunu sorguluyor
Örneğin Amerikan şirketlerinden birisi
işe alırken bir kadına da ya da en az
iki yıl içerisinde evlenmez siniz veya
çocuk sahibi olmazsınız Siz iş alırız
diyor yine bizim ülkemizdeki
şirketlerden birisi yönetim pozisyondaki
bir kadın adaya bekarsınız
evleneceksiniz Muhtemelen Veya birkaç
yıl sonra çocuk sahibi olacaksınız en
iyi adayı Sizsiniz ama biz sizi tercih
edemiyoruz bu sebeplerden dolayı
diyebiliyor sonrasıyla Aslında o
ayrımcılığı veya
cinsiyete dayalı rollerden kaynaklanan
sebepleri yönetim kademelerinin sıklıkla
görüyoruz
bütün fonksiyonlarını anlattık ara bu
dostum siyah üst düzey yönetici nasıl
olur kadınları engel koymazsak sınır
koymazsak kadınlarda olabildiğince üst
düzey yönetici düzeyinde
faydalanabiliriz kadın isterse her şeyi
yapabilir Yeter ki kadına eşit mesafede
saygılı davranarak engel tanımayarak bir
fırsat yaratalım Tıpkı bugün burada
benimle beraber aynı sahneyi paylaşacak
yönetici ve belirli pozisyonlarda yer
alan kadınlarımız olduğu gibi teşekkür
ediyorum
[Alkış]